VICE-PRESIDENT PENCE WHO
PREVIOUSLY WORKED WITH STRZOK ON
THE CLINTON E-MAIL CASE.
JOINING ME, GREG JARED AND TOM
FENTON AND CONGRESSMAN MIKE
TURNER.
GENTLEMEN, THANK YOU FOR JOINING
ME THIS INC
ME THIS EVC
ME THIS EVENING.
GREG, I'LL START WITH YOU.
WHILE ALL OF WHAT WE HAVE
EXPERIENCED HAS BEEN SURPRISING
TO ALL OF US.
NONE OF US ARE NAIVE.
ALL OF US HAVE EXPERIENCE.
ALL OF US REMEMBER DIXON.
WE ALL KNOW THAT THE GOVERNMENT
CAN BE SECRETIVE.
THIS HAS BEEN EXTRAORDINARY AT
ANY LEVEL.
WHAT IS YOUR TAKE NOW WITH THIS
NEW REVELATION?
IS THIS SOMETHING PAR FOR THE
COURSE?
OR DOES THIS TAKE IT TO CHANGE
AND TURN INTO SOME PLACE QUITE
DIFFERENT?
>> IF THE EVIDENCE IS THERE, AND
I WOULD LIKE TO SEE THE
EXPLANATIONS FOR THESE TEXT
MESSAGES, IF THE EVIDENCE IS
THERE, I DON'T KNOW HOW YOU
EXPLAIN THESE MESSAGES.
IT DOES APPEAR THEY ARE TRYING
TO PLANT A MOLE WITHIN THE
TRANSITION TEAM TO SPY ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
WE ALREADY KNOW AS BILL BARR
POINTED OUT TO GREAT CONTROVERSY
THAT THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN WAS
BEING SPIED ON.
THERE WAS ELECTRONIC
SURVEILLANCE, A CONFIDENTIAL
INFORMANT AND NOW APPARENTLY
THERE MAY HAVE BEEN A MOLE.
THE PRESIDENT WAS CORRECT WHEN
HE PLAYED THE COMMENT A MOMENT
AGO.
THIS WAS AN ATTEMPT AT A SILENT,
NONVIOLENT COUP BASED ON PHONEY
INFORMATION TO DRIVE HIM FROM
OFFICE.
CLINTON WAS THE FINANCIER,
BRENNAN WAS THE INSTIGATOR AND
CLAPPER WAS THE LEAKER AND YOU
HAD CHRISTOPHER STEELE AND GLEN
SIMPSON WHO CREATED IT ALL AND
COMEY AND McCABE AND STRZOK AND
PAGE WERE DRIVING THE ATTEMPT TO
COUP.
>> TOM, YOUR ORGANIZATION,
JUDICIAL WATCH, HAS BEEN PUSHING
FOR YEARS LIKE A DOG THAT WILL
NOT LET GO.
SOME OF US, SOME INDIVIDUALS,
SOME AMERICANS THINK WELL THIS
CAN'T BE HAPPENING.
THIS IS CRAZY TALK.
EVERY DAY, THERE SEEMS TO BE
SOMETHING MORE REMARKABLE.
WITH THE WORK YOU HAVE DONE,
WHERE WOULD SOMETHING LIKE THIS
ULTIMATELY GO?
WHAT DO YOU THINK WE CAN EXPECT
AS WE MOVE FORWARD?
>> THE MORE WE LEARN, THE WORSE
IT LOOKS IN TERMS OF THE SPYGATE
COUP EFFORT AGAINST PRESIDENT
TRUMP.
THEY ARE HIDING TEXT MESSAGES
FROM ANDREW McCABE, PETER STRZOK
AND LISA PAGE.
THERE ARE OTHERS THAT ARE OUT
THERE.
YOU START OFF TALKING ABOUT THE
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN.
YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER THAT THE
DEMOCRAT PARTY APPARATUS WAS
INVOLVED IN THIS.
THE DEMOCRAT NATIONAL COMMITTEE
SPENT MONEY ON THIS EFFORT TO
OVERTHROW THE PRESIDENT BY
WORKING WITH RUSSIA INTEL.
THEY WERE MEETING WITH THE FBI
GENERAL COUNSEL JUST SHORTLY
BEFORE THE ELECTION.
THE LAWYER FOR THE DNC AND
HILLARY CLINTON.
JOE BIDEN WAS IN THIS INFAMOUS
EARLY JANUARY, 2017 OVER OFFICE
MEETING WITH BARACK OBAMA AND
SUSAN RICE AND JAMES COMEY,
WHERE THEY ALL TALKED EXCITEDLY
ABOUT THE DOSSIER JUST BEFORE
COMEY WAS LAUNCHED BY OBAMA WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP TEAM THROUGH THE
DOSSIER.
>> I THINK WE ARE GOING TO SEE
AN EFFORT TO MAKE IT SEEM AS
THOUGH JOE BIDEN WAS DROPPED IN
FROM THE PLANET MARS AND WAS
NEVER INVOLVED IN THIS.
HE HAS BEEN INVOLVED A GREAT
DEAL.
HE IS AN EXPERIENCED MAN AND
KNOWS WHAT'S GOING ON.
ALL OF US, MIKE, WHEN WE DEAL
WITH THINGS LIKE THIS, PEOPLE
MENTION WATERGATE.
THIS IS EXCLUSIVELY DIFFERENT.
WATERGATE WAS A TEAM OF PEOPLE
AND THE PRESIDENT INVOLVING
RE-ELECTION TRYING TO GET
INFORMATION ON THE OPPONENT.
THIS IS AN AGENCY, THE HIGHEST
LAW ENFORCEMENT OF THE NATION,
COLLUDING AND SPYING AND WORKING
TO CHANGE AN ELECTION THAT WAS
LEGAL AND USURP A DUAL ELECTED
PRESIDENT.
THAT IS SOMETHING WE HAVE NEVER
SEEN BEFORE?
WOULD YOU AGREE, MIKE?
>> ONE OF THE THINGS THAT I
THINK WE HAVE THAT WE WOULD BE
VERY CONCERNED ABOUT IS THE FACT
THAT HERE WE HAVE OUR DEMOCRAT
INSTITUTIONS BEING UNDERMINED BY
THE INTELLIGENCE COMMUNITY, OUR
LAW ENFORCEMENT COMMUNITY, WHO
ARE ENTRUSTED WITH TOOLS THAT
ARE SUPPOSED TO BE KEEPING US
SAFE.
THEY ARE SUPPOSED TO BE PART OF
WHAT GOES TO THE HEART OF OUR
NATIONAL SECURITY.
INSTEAD, THEY ARE USING THESE
TOOLS TO UNDERMINE OUR DEMOCRAT
PRINCIPLES, TO UNDERMINE A DUAL
ELECTED PRESIDENT.
WHAT WE HAVE SEEN NOW, EVEN WITH
BRENNAN, CLAPPER AND COMEY, AND
THE THINGS THEY HAVE SAID ON
NATIONAL TV, POST THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION, THEIR ABSOLUTE
OPPOSITION TO THIS PRESIDENT.
IT IS EVIDENT IN THE WAY WE SEE
THE ABUSE OF POWER AND THE
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND THE
FBI AND OUR INTELLIGENCE AGENCY.
>> WITH THE MUELLER REPORT DONE,
WE FINALLY HAVE A SENSE THAT
THIS IS SERIOUS BUSINESS AND
THAT WE CAN ACTUALLY LOOK AT IT
WITHOUT BEING AFRAID AND WITH
THE SERIOUSNESS OF TAKING CARE
OF BUSINESS, THAT IT IS NOT
REALLY ABOUT TRUMP, IT IS NOT
EVEN A PARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS IS ABOUT WHAT CAN HAPPEN IN
A POWER FRAMEWORK WHERE THERE
HAS BEEN NO ACCOUNTABILITY FOR
GENERATIONS.
DO YOU THINK WE ARE FINALLY AT
THIS POINT THAT WE CAN DO THIS
AND THAT WE WILL DO IT IN
LOOKING AT IT SERIOUSLY AND
COMPLETELY?
>> IF I WERE JAMES COMEY, ANDREW
McCABE, PETER STRZOK, BRENNAN,
CLAPPER, I WOULD BE VERY, VERY
WORRIED AND NOT SLEEPING VERY
WELL.
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL HAS SPENT
A YEAR EXAMINING THE ORIGINS OF
THE TRUMP RUSSIA COLLUSION
INVESTIGATION.
>> WE NORMALLY SEE GOVERNMENT
INVESTIGATIONS, COMMITTEE STUFF.
>> THIS IS DIFFERENT.
>> IT NEVER BECOMES ANYTHING.
THERE IS NEVER A RESULT.
>> I THINK YOU WILL SEE CRIMINAL
REFERRALS IN THE NEXT 60 DAYS IN
THE I.G. OVER TO THE DEPARTMENT
OF JUSTICE.
BILL BARR HAS MADE IT ABUNDANTLY
CLEAR HE IS SERIOUS ABOUT
UNDERTAKING A LEGITIMATE
INVESTIGATION, BECAUSE HE
REALIZES THE EVIDENCE APPEARS TO
BE THERE THAT IF THE FBI, IN
PARTICULAR, THERE WAS A CESSPOOL
OF CORPORATION AMONG THE UPPER
ECHELONS.
>> THIS IS OUR CHANCE TO SAY TO
EVERYONE IN THE POLITICAL FIELD
WE ARE SERIOUS ABOUT TAKING CARE
OF THESE ISSUES, THAT THERE WILL
BE REPERCUSSIONS.
OUR INFRASTRUCTURE RELIES ON THE
LEGITIMACY THAT THE AMERICAN